hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to through the woods now
this is just a demo of an upcoming
horror game those made specifically for
PAX East 2016 and I was at PAX East 2016
and I had not heard of the game so I
didn't even know that there was a demo
available until just now so with this
game we're gonna find out can I whoa
what did I do
what the hell did I just whoa
oh god oh jeez mangy Scoob
whoa oh holy [ __ ] what did I do
I'm just trying to play the game man
oops it's ready to play the game oh man
I think um maybe control it oh okay I
saw I spent Jackie there on the ground
it felt like something inside me broke
I suddenly realized that this was really
happening he'd been taken from me I was
his mother I was supposed to protect him
he trusted me and I let him down as I
had so many times before I promised
myself I would find him and bring him
back I just hope that was a promise I
could keep me too lady so this lady lost
her son and we got to go through the
woods to get him back which is kind of a
common theme in horror games not that
I'm knocking this game I don't want to
make any criticisms about this game
especially just the early into the game
but I do say that this game looks good
and that is often a qualification for a
game being that's not often a
qualification for a game being good I
want to be very specific oh hi
why is the moon'll splode who sploded
the moon why is that that's cool
but why see this is what I like that's
an environmental clue that's that's
something that's world building that's
just there and it's not explained but a
lot of assumptions can be based on that
and that makes me thinks there's aliens
involved in this I don't know why or
maybe it's some distorted version of
Earth I like that a lot can I run that's
flashlight
running where am i go wow what the hell
is that who built a fortress out here
who built a Skyrim ass fort whoa hey oh
this is very Skyrim
wait a minute here hello how it do what
is that mirac stud oh man
that's weird and cool but weird why is
that there why is easier what is all
this oh my god it's totally Skyrim I'm
not wrong in that everyone's getting the
vibes right holy [ __ ]
so what is what is all this doing here I
mean ah be wound I didn't think they
could open hello I anybody home that
looks like a comfortable bed oh is this
my room am I gonna be staying the night
here okay whoa it's a Nordic helmet okay
so maybe the reason that I'm thinking
that it's Skyrim is because this is all
based on like Nordic ancient
architecture and stuff like that and and
it's just seemingly in the same place
because that's what Skyrim was it was
like the the North belongs to the Nords
but you know all that northern culture
ye olde Viking lands
Oh place looks abandoned yeah no joke it
looks ancient where else would it be a
bit and you're coming in with uh the
flashlight and there's like medieval
Helms that are rusted and old but who
lit these what's on the table X okay
text a bit further on he found a crooked
ram's horn and soon he found the other
look at what I found boys he shouted
what did you find now then said his
brother's to ram's horns answered ask
Aladdin throw them away what are you
doing with them they said contemptuously
no I have things to do and these will do
it ask a lot and I don't want to know
what you're gonna do with those ram
horns and I don't know why that's
important for what I'm doing here
what was it the controls are only
slightly wonky I have to admit it might
be manna can you play with the massive
keyboard hey let me see oh you can oh
why was I having trouble oh this is
gonna be much easier than what I was
doing before okay man I kind of got
sidetracked from everything because I
was so interested in the like
environment which is a good thing I
gotta admit in a horror game the
environment is very important to
building the world like like the thing
with the moon a horror game is like
emphasized on what goes around in the
world hello the old bastard came to the
village yester
the Craven [ __ ] son took Jorns boy away
the bastard no one saw him come though
we set a watch some weeks ago the boy
didn't make a sound the wretched thing
we'd all a mine to go up there at last
and put an end to this but for the gates
the cursed gates won't open to those
such as us all's we can do is biden hope
Jorns boy was the last the corruption of
the man his heart if he has one must be
rotted as a month Dead swine and our
gods do nothing the curse on the whole
festering pile of them and curse on the
murdering bastard Eric okay so so [ __ ]
so why is Eric just given free rein and
why are you bothered by some unopen
engage
very I'm interested but I'm very
confused
hi okay
ah is that the month old dead swine I
was hearing so much about okay go in
fine I'm afraid oh hey who's there oh
hey hi can you open up for me oh it
opened up for me whoa okay
who's doing that okay fine
[ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] hello okay hello
yeah it's gone hello after the doors
mysteriously open and then you wander
inside and still hear footsteps outside
the doors okay okay
what's happening
should I go up there man I don't like
how narrow the view is I know it's
supposed to be over the shoulder
perspective and sometimes that's good
for games but it's just combined with
the slightly wonky controls it's just a
little disorienting here all right Eric
told us tonight of the pact and war long
ago tis said you could hear the terror
of Ragnarok all around even as our
people were brought here to safety the
earth shook huge structures of Asgard
fell from the sky over the mountain we
now call fog for yelled Fenrir killed
Odin laid waste to nearly all the
world's only we hardened Minnie's halt
remained well I don't know how true that
is considering the world seemed to have
progressed since the days of old but I'm
not sure what do I know I'm just a
mother looking for her son hello oh hi
how you doing how are you doing
dead in your bed I see asleep on the job
well I won't tell your boss like I said
it's just really disorienting
disorientating disorienting based on how
close it is sometimes to this go donut
yeah where's my son can you tell me I
seem to have lost him so somewhere
around here there's a mystery to be
solved but I don't know why my boy was
taken here unless it's the same person
that was taking children from long long
ago and I don't even know how I was able
to track them back to this place and I
don't even know why this place was lost
to the ages if Odin really is dead
there's no hope for the rest of us we
mere mortal
I swear I hear footsteps
I would have what is this big rock thing
is this important
it looks kind of maybe a little bit
important now man is that recent
decapitated cow head something along
those lines okay because they'll follow
the obvious trail but all right then
good thing I wasn't able to properly
face that whatever that was okay bye I'm
gonna go in here now I'm gonna go
through this slightly ajar door ooh this
looks good
am I finally gonna go through the woods
yeah all righty then well bring it on
you're a [ __ ] bastard I'm on the way to
kick your ass to get my son back I'm a
mom on a mission and you ain't gonna
stop me maybe maybe you will stop me oh
it's the blasted moon again good job
right okay ah good I was wondering when
the creeping bass section was gonna
start good lightning on a clear sky
that's reassuring I'm sure that doesn't
bode ill will for me and death is not on
the horizon [ __ ] you hello hi weird
ancient magical Nordic symbols of mercs
dad I can't interact with you so I don't
exactly know what that's gonna be doing
unless that's like some weird at the
real checkpoint system which it very
well could be I'm not on our sensual
hello ah yes the deep thumping rumbles
setting will be moaning I don't remember
allowing anybody to be moaning in my
vicinity that's a lot of moaning
that's a bit more moaning than I signed
out for I just signed up for maybe
moderate amounts of moaning whoa is that
a thing what the [ __ ] is that whoa what
the [ __ ] is on control what am I
supposed to do Oh I'm [ __ ]
I'm clobbered ugh what am I supposed to
do about you [ __ ] you oh geez okay
ah good it wasn't it wasn't it was a
checkpoint system and that was a troll
and I'm assuming I was supposed to run
past that very expeditiously oh it's
much easier to see without the
flashlight enabled oh that's cool
actually okay so that's actually a good
thing because I don't necessarily need
the flashlight right now I only need it
when I'm able to look for things and
that's actually good because the
flashlight was casting harsh shadows
anyway in making it very difficult to
see ah so I need to creep uh-huh now
what I need to do
where's mr. mone huh
where's sir moans a lot is he not there
why here I hear the moaning binge over
yonder way but I'm not gonna turn on my
flashlight not my flashlight my
flashlight oh I think he spotted me
well [ __ ] [ __ ] balls I'm out of here
rats don't vote on me don't phone me
don't loan me bro man I gotta commend
that guys moaning ability it's it's
non-stop moaning mister oh jeez
he's the moan master Oh God he's the
troll moan master good god stop it man
there's no need for moans and groans
this deep into the woods okay that's
probably not a way to go little
flashlight brah help over here
all right so where the hell are we going
now hey also why in modern society in
the days of flashlights and stuff are
there still trolls and stuff in the
woods that doesn't seem very normal then
again a lot of things in these types of
games aren't exactly normal
hello oh that's not good when I saw
Ben's jacket there on the ground it felt
like something inside me broke
I suddenly realized that this was really
happening he'd been taken from me its
coat his little coat lying that dark
place I was his mother I was supposed to
protect him
he trusted me and I let him down as I
had so many times before his jacket was
a symbol of my failure I promised myself
I would find him and bring him back
I just hope oh oh no not there don't do
that oh I just got done with mr. mone
oh man moody mone was moaning up a storm
in mopey moaning moaning woods
oh man call this game through the moans
ah [ __ ] man I know it's a demo but I
just got into it I was just figuring it
out oh man so that's the end of the demo
through the woods the full game is gonna
come out some point in the future but
man this has a lot of potential
I love the world-building that's what I
really love I really do love the
world-building and I kind of now
connecting the dots between this is
assuming that the UH the Nordic
mythology is real and I'm assuming what
they mean by the pieces of Asgard
falling apart is the moon exploding but
somehow life still continued and man
there's still trolls and monsters in the
woods so this could be very good and I'm
looking forward to this and seeing the
full game come out I just don't know
when that's gonna be so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
working didn't work on that other guy
question